what's going on guys this is Rob and you
read that title correctly all the
superheroes die so this is a story
called Days of Future Past doomsday and
this is designed to kind of explain
exactly how events transpired that led
to the original Days of Future Past
storyline for those of you guys who
don't know about Days of Future Past It
Was Written in Uncanny X-Men 141 and 142
by Chris Claremont and basically the
Sentinels took over North America and
eradicated pretty much all the
superheroes in existence those who
didn't die were just basically sent off
to internment camps awaiting their
executions so what ends up happening
here is this basically picks up in what
you and I could refer to as like year
zero which is effectively the
assassination of Senator Robert Kelly
now there is a differentiation between
how this story unfolds and the original
Days of Future Past which leads me to
believe this isn't an alternate reality
and the reason why I say that is that in
the original Days of Future Past it was
mystique and her Brotherhood of evil
mutants that killed Senator Robert Kelly
Professor Xavier and Maura McTaggart in
order to establish that mutants should
not be messed with and that's when
everything went sideways here it's just
Robert Kelly and in fact Charles Xavier
will show up over the course of the
story but within four years of Robert
Kelly's assassination William Striker is
sworn in as president of the United
States now this is a horrific
circumstance and the reason why is
because William Striker is a religious
fundamentalist this guy leads a group
called The purifiers their whole Charter
is that they believe it's their mission
from God to destroy the mutant
population now William Striker can't
simply just Rebrand the United States
Army as like the purifiers and then just
start taking out mutants everywhere they
go there is the game of politics and so
in the fifth year the United States
Congress passes the mutant Control Act
this is exactly what it sounds like it
is a bill passed by Congress to
basically restrict the rights of the
mutant population Now Matt Murdoch
Daredevil ends up approaching the
Supreme Court and makes an argument and
essentially saying that because the
mutant population are still citizens of
the United States and are at their very
core human it's restricting the rights
of U.S citizens I.E it violates the U.S
Constitution the United States Supreme
Court agrees with him and they overturn
the mutant control act now in the
original Days of Future Past we didn't
know that it was Matt Murdock who had
done this we just simply knew that the
Supreme Court overturned the mutant
Control Act the other part is that in
the original Days of Future Past there
was no reason to believe William Striker
was President largely because his
character had not been created in Marvel
Comics by that point in time but it does
make sense right like the original
depiction of the president and then
William Striker they look very similar
and so by year six the United States
government does exactly what it did in
the original Days of Future Past story
it launches The Sentinel program now
something to understand about this whole
Sentinel program and the history behind
it is super fascinating you had a guy by
the name of Bolivar Trask Bolivar Trask
was the one who originally created the
Sentinels but these are not necessarily
Bolivar Trask Sentinels they are but
they're not the signals that you're
familiar with from like X-Men the
Animated Series and so on and so forth
that's Stephen Lang not to be confused
with Scotland the two of them are not
related but basically after ball of our
trash was originally defeated in the
X-Men Comics The Sentinel program was
handed over to Stephen Lang who
basically redesigned them updated them
with newer technology and sent them out
into the world such as it is it doesn't
look like Stephen Lang has any
involvement here so effectively they're
using the Stephen Lang design but ball
of our Trask and the Trask Dynasty are
essentially the ones behind it but by
year 11 the Sentinels are sent out into
the world they're really into the United
States itself but instead of just
immediately attacking everything what
they end up doing is just kind of
walking around the idea is that they're
there quote unquote for safety right to
be a kind of non-human police force what
the Sentinels are actually doing is
scanning and cataloging mutants studying
their powers learning what they're
capable of and so by year 18 we end up
in Stamford Connecticut now for those of
you guys who are familiar with Stanford
Connecticut you pretty much already know
what's about to go down here for those
of you guys who aren't Stamford
Connecticut was the Catalyst for the
Civil War event in Marvel Comics
basically things transpire almost the
exact same way but it doesn't lead to
Civil War instead what ended up
happening here is that because of the
passage of the mutant Control Act The
Avengers resigned in solidarity with the
mutant population exactly how that is in
solidarity of mutants I don't
necessarily know because I don't see the
Avengers fighting alongside them right
so what you end up getting by the
federal government is basically the
creation of the Defenders now this is
not the first time in Marvel Comics that
the federal government has created a
federally sanctioned superhero team and
in fact if my memory serves me the
original X Factor from Bob Layton and
then eventually Walter and Louise
Simonson yes that team was composed of
like the original X-Men just on a team
of their own when Marvel relaunched
everything in the 1990s and you got
Uncanny X-Men and then X-Men volume 2. X
Factor ended up getting a new roster
with like strong guy and people like
that but they were a
government-sanctioned superhero team so
it's not that uncommon to see and you
even saw it more recently in the events
of like dark rain right and so on and so
forth but the kicker here is that while
these guys look like Avengers they're
not a really good example of this is
that instead of Steve Rogers as Captain
America it's John Walker I.E us agent
instead of Iron Man you basically have
Obadiah stain operating as the Iron
Monger making himself look like Iron Man
but the thing about this is that as far
as the X-Men are concerned it's just
them fighting a villainous group out in
Stamford but then Wolverine picks up on
ascent and he realizes something's wrong
here right like there's something going
on especially specifically he figures
out that when it comes to Nitro his
sense all wrong right that he's got some
kind of chemical or drug in his system
and that's when we realize it's
basically just like it was at the
beginning of civil war that Nitro has
taken mutant growth hormone basically a
drug that amplifies the powers of
mutants and because nitro's ability is
to self-detonate and let off a massive
explosion without destroying himself is
exactly what happens here he blows up
the entirety of Stamford Connecticut
boom president of the United States
declares martial law now here's where I
kind of disagree with exactly what's
going on here right we do get Valerie
Cooper who's the office of National
Emergency liaison for mutant Affairs for
those of you guys who don't know about
Valerie Cooper this girl was like
hardcore man like the commission on
superhuman activities if you guys
remember like the old Chris Claremont
stuff from back in the 70s and 80s that
was all Valerie Cooper in effect she was
kind of like the liaison to the
superhero community and she was the one
that would keep them on a tight leash as
far as the federal government was
concerned because back at the time when
Days of Future Past was originally
written the general consensus when it
came to like the entirety of the
superhero community and you saw it like
the Fantastic Four the X-Men Captain
America comics so on and so forth is
that the federal government was very
much cracking down on superheroes being
able to have this kind of like free
reign out in the world and all the kind
of stuff that came with it where I
disagree with what's happening is we've
got Henry Peter guyrick and Wilson Fisk
along with Simon Trask when it came to
the original Days of Future Past event
there was no internal human Circle and
in fact the Sentinels had basically just
become self-aware what I do like is that
it looks like they're kind of starting
with this but they're not going to end
with this because what Simon Trask does
is he speaks up and he says okay we may
have an unintended consequence here and
when the question is asked what's the
unintended consequence he says the
Signal's primary directive is to
maintain order and protect the populace
I'm concerned they might determine that
the most efficient means to do so is to
simply just take over and when the
questions asked what does this have to
do with Stamford Connecticut the
response assignment is martial law means
the suspension of civil rights taking
control of America is certainly easier
once democracy is on a timeout after all
isn't that why the four of us
orchestrated Stanford and so where
Wilson Fisk speaks up and he says you're
saying that you think at some point the
Sentinels will decide we're working for
them instead of the other way around the
response of traffic is I think they may
already have done that now here's the
reason why that's so important in the
Days of Future Past comic when the
Sentinels took over while we weren't
explicitly told exactly what their line
of logic was it was pretty simple and in
fact X-Men the Animated Series explained
it perfectly that when the Sentinels
were tasked with basically seeing
mutants as the enemy it was a logical
choice for Humanity an illogical choice
for the Sentinels because Sentinels are
just robots they just follow orders
right they really don't understand
Nuance with Humanity we routinely look
for reasons to justify our belief
systems even if our justifications are
nonsensical right we can just make up
any reason we want to and then go
forward believing that for a robot it
makes no logical sense and so the
Sentinels would look at the mutant
population they would look at the human
population and they would say by all
standards of measurement mutants are
humans therefore if our task is to
control the mutant population that means
control the human population and that's
why in the original Days of Future Past
storyline this Sentinels took over
everything and in fact a perfect example
of the nonsensical logic of humanity
comes in the form of Simon Trask
debating Steve Rogers on national
television and what ends up happening is
Steve Rogers presents basically The
Logical argument right the one that you
or I or anybody would expect to see
which is to say what's the difference
between like The Avengers or the X-Men
or the Fantastic Four right like The
Avengers in Fantastic Four routinely
saved the world and we're championed as
Heroes the X-Men do the same thing and
you basically see them as like criminals
people that need to be contained and
controlled but the response of Simon
Trask is we're talking about two
distinctly different things number one
The Avengers all gain their powers
through some kind of external means you
Steve Rogers got your powers by way of
the super soldier serum that's the
Incredible Hulk was a result of gamma
radiation Thor is a Godly being so on
and so forth with mutants their powers
develop during puberty so are we really
supposed to just kind of stand idly by
as a 13 year old who has no real
understanding of the full totality of
their actions and the impact that they
have who has the ability to simply just
wipe out an entire school system with
some kind of an explosion or shoot
lasers out of his eyes or read the minds
of other people do we just kind of let
that kid exist like who knows what might
happen in that circumstance are you
really going to tell me that we don't
have the right to be afraid great right
that regulating these human weapons
isn't the safe and necessary thing to do
this is not Prejudice Captain it's
common sense and that's really where the
Crux of the entire argument came from
that if mutants are people who develop
their powers at such a time in their
life to where they can't truly
understand the consequences of their
actions should they be allowed to just
roam free out there in the world or
should they be regulated and controlled
the same way that we control guns and
different things along those lines
that's where the arguments get
interesting because then as people we
were just kind of arbitrarily say but
like they're human though so we can't do
that because there's just an arbitrary
difference that we've created between a
dangerous human and like a dangerous
weapon right you know so it's really
interesting how this whole thing unfolds
but where the heroes really start to die
really comes by way of Spider-Man and
the reason why is because what we're
told is that as time progressed humanity
stopped differentiating between Heroes
and mutants and what initially started
out as anti-mutant fervor became
anti-hero fervor they started going
after everybody and so there's like this
great big huge protest that erupts
between mutants and humans Spider-Man
steps in he tries to quell everything
and they beat him to death they
literally kill Spider-Man now one of the
things that's kind of discussed there is
that Peter Parker could have stood up to
them and he could have fought his way
out but the concern is that he didn't
really want to hurt anybody I got to
tell you man if I'm Peter Parker and I'm
being attacked by a mob of people
everybody's gonna get one why
everybody's getting attacked I'm making
it out of there just be glad I don't
kill you in the process
right but then following that you pick
up with professor Charles Xavier and
this is where things get interesting
because what's been going on in the
midst of all of this is Magneto is
making his move and where this does kind
of seem to come out of left field the
logic of Magneto is actually incredibly
sound here because with the X-Men trying
to find Magneto and Magneto going after
like the world's nuclear arsenals of
course Shield steps in Shield AIDS the
X-Men and helping to locate the
Brotherhood of evil mutants but then the
group goes directly after Magneto and
this is one of those instances where I
guarantee you guys are going to look at
this and you're going to be like
Magneto's 100 right because what ends up
happening is where Xavier says no we
can't do this Magneto you're playing
into their hands they want to see a
violent mutant out there doing violent
things to justify their belief systems
the response of Magneto to Charles
Xavier is you're talking as if they're
using any kind of logic they've made up
their minds the mutant Control Act has
been passed like they're targeting us
there's no more like trying to stop this
from happening there's no more like
reasoning with them and trying to get
them to understand why he's like they
are counting on nothing except your
client acquiescence and he says they
pass laws to make criminals of us and
you do nothing they send out Sentinels
to march across our country and you do
nothing they use us as a pretext to
declare martial law and you do nothing
tell me Charles all these men and women
so many enemies who hate and fear us and
yet the only person you and your X-Men
stand against is me and so it's such a
phenomenal argument here because the
response of the X-Men is like we're
coming after you because you're trying
to take over the world and Magneto's
whole stance is to protect us from them
because this is no longer a debate or
this is no longer a discussion that
could be had it's open War right are we
fighting in the streets no not
necessarily but they've made their move
they're Waging War against us and he
says they'll come for us and for all of
us and we'll tell ourselves as we always
have that it's okay they'll brand us
like cattle and we'll tell ourselves
that it's no different than a driver's
license they'll put us in ghettos and
we'll tell ourselves it's just for a
little while then they'll put us in cans
and we'll tell ourselves it will end
soon we'll be right about that much at
least you think I'm speaking of the
future I am not I'm telling you about
the past I know it can happen because
I've watched it happen Magneto is
literally looking at a repeat of
everything that happened during World
War II in Germany and he's not wrong
right that in a lot of ways even as a
story is kind of being told in hindsight
Xavier is being seen as a guy who has
this naive optimism right that in the
face of a asteroid moments from crashing
into the Earth and annihilating all all
life across the planet there's still
hope that the day can be saved we're
well far past that point there's nothing
to be done here right the end is nigh
and so what we end up doing is jumping
aboard a basically a plane which is a
response to Magneto which is to say the
government's trying to move these
different nuclear weapons to a more
secure location because they realize
Magneto is going after that the problem
is that Jason Wingard Mastermind a
mutant that has the ability to
manipulate the five senses is basically
aboard this plane so when you have kitty
pride and Jean Gray and cyclops who get
here this takes place after the events
of dark Phoenix why does that matter
because Jason Wingard in that story had
screwed with the mind of Gene gray and
led her to becoming the dark Phoenix in
the first place and so as I don't really
know if I would call it payback but kind
of that victimization that she
experienced she attacked Jason wengard
and in fact she actually kills him but
in the process she inadvertently
activates the nuclear weapons with 15
seconds counting down these bombs go off
no one's really able to keep it
contained but Cyclops is basically
phased by Kitty Pride meaning she's able
to make him intangible and so while it
doesn't really kill him it does burn his
eyes out of his head so they actually
have to remove his eyeballs at a future
point in time meaning he has no powers
whatsoever and so following this what
you end up doing is you pick up at
basically the funeral of Jean Gray right
that everybody's kind of there in
attendance but you effectively have
Magneto who shows up who wasn't
necessarily welcomed and in fact while a
fight breaks out initially between
Wolverine and Magneto and Wolverine
pulls a plastic gun with polymer bullets
that Magneto wouldn't be able to stop
Cyclops decides he wants to hear what
Magneto has to say and in effect it's a
ceasefire right it's a truce that it is
really Magneto and Xavier agreeing to
kind of work together but for the most
part to try things Xavier's way and to
see if there's a way to bring some kind
of peaceful resolution into this entire
conflict spoiler alert there's not right
so what ends of happening is we get this
really really cool monologue right where
we're told despite everything thing the
professor never hated Magneto it was
worse than that his heart broke for
never being able to bring his friend to
his side Magneto was right of course
about things getting worse the first
thing president Stryker did was get
Congress to reinstate the mutant Control
Act this time the Supreme Court chose
not to stop it under the mutant Control
Act the government began placing mutants
in relocation centers quote unquote for
their own protection some mutants and
their families fled North to Canada but
most stayed in America under the
mistaken belief that things would
eventually get better and they didn't
right Magneto's prophecy came to pass
because if humanity is really good at
doing anything it's just constantly
repeating cycles of events that have
happened in the past especially if we
never learned from them and so what ends
up happening is that by year 19 Henry
Peter guyrick shows up to professor
Charles Xavier and he essentially tells
them we've got warrants for every single
one of your X-Men and you to be taken to
a real location Center so you can either
come willingly or you can come
forcefully but Xavier calls us Bluff
because what he realizes is that there
are the Optics of what would happen if
the human population just attacked the
entirety of the X-Men mansion even all
of the Angry and anti-mutant fervor
that's out there people wouldn't
necessarily side with like an unprovoked
attack against innocent people
especially if the X-Men just did nothing
and allowed themselves to be killed on
National Television they wouldn't really
be martyrs per se although they kind of
would because what that could
potentially do is turn popular sentiment
or public sentiment against the federal
government then you have 300 million
people who have always war against you
and so in response to that what Henry
Peter gyrick and Valerie Cooper do is
they bring in general Thunderbolt roths
right the guy who traditionally goes
after the Incredible Hulk and they task
him with launching an attack against the
X-Men right and then in turn trying to
spin it in order to make it look like
the X-Men attacked first general
Thunderbolt Ross chooses not to because
despite how he may be portrayed in the
X-Men Comics he is a man of Honor right
he wouldn't really go after the X-Men
unprovoked or attack people unprovoked
more so than that right the Posse
commentatus Act of 1878 the United
States Army or the United States
military cannot enforce laws within the
borders of the United States so
ultimately General Thunderbolt Ross is
relieved of command somebody else was
put in his place and the attack goes
down the main X-Men roster are basically
led to a conflict out in your Island so
the entirety of the X-Men mansion is
basically laid empty in response to that
and while that happens William Striker
and his forces attacked the X-Men
mansion Professor Xavier is there to
witness all the death and destruction
Iceman is one of the first to fall right
he's just grabbed by a sentinel and he's
one part melted one part destroyed right
but literally just shattered and that's
the end of him Xavier tries to use his
telepathy to take over the minds of the
various soldiers who were standing out
there and are intending to invade the
entire Mansion but Frank Simpson also
known as nuke who's historically been
part of weapons plus this guy fires off
a shot and kills Xavier on the spot
following that you have guys like
Nightcrawler who were destroyed by
Sentinels it's just like Michael
Corleone at the end of Godfather right
like executing the heads of the five
families it's a multi-pronged strike
against everybody except for the core
X-Men so the only real X-Men that you
have left here are like storm Colossus
Forge Kitty Pride right like Wolverine
that's more or less it but the
leadership is essentially gone and so
what ends up happening is that in this
moment of realizing that things are
going to go belly up that things are in
the darkest of times there's a kind of
connection that's been forming for quite
some time between Kitty pride and
Colossus and the two of them get married
but one of the funny things is that
we're told it would be like the last
happy day that anybody would really
experience for any measure of time
because following that for the X-Men
it's just basically guerrilla warfare
tactics they're jumping from one
location to the next by year 20 they're
in madrapore and they're just moving
from one safe location constantly
underground they never really can
operate out of a singular base of
operations more so than that the signals
have evolved to a point where now
they're sending out nimrods why does
that matter because the Nimrod Sentinel
model was a version of The Sentinel that
not only could detect what a mutant's
power was but could also develop a
counter measure to it and figure out
what psychological or emotional
weaknesses they would have and use it
against them right to fight against the
Nimrod was to fight against a sentinel
that could attack you both physically
mentally and emotionally it was one of
the most devastating Sentinels to ever
exist out there imagine fighting three
more so than that and the initial attack
against the X-Men mansion Rachel Summers
the daughter of Jean Gray and cyclops in
this universe was one of the only people
to survive but she was taken by the US
government specifically Ahab but she was
taken and she was turned into a Hound
what does that mean a Hound is a mutant
that was used to hunt other mutants and
because she was such a powerful telepath
it made perfect sense she would be used
for that purpose one of the first people
she attacked is Storm now what's also
crazy about this is Franklin Richards
does exist in this universe and he did
exist in Days of Future Past the
difference is that Franklin Richard's
reality warping abilities were nowhere
near as advanced as they became during
like Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four
run when he was older a lot of that was
because when Franklin was younger Reed
Richards put mental blocks in his head
to keep him from accessing the full
totality of his powers more or less it
looks like during the days of future
past those mental blocks were never
removed so he's just like a really
capable telepath and telekinetic but we
don't know if he'll ever tap into his
powers in the original Days of Future
Past story he never did he never
accessed the full tote reality of his
reality warping abilities he did in Days
of Future present but he never did in
Days of Future Past and so were storm
and Franklin Richards are both taken
into custody by the U.S government and
taken into an internment camp Forge and
Beast are two of the last X-Men
remaining and Beast agrees to stay there
and to help Forge face off against the
Sentinels Beast is eradicated in an
instant he's destroyed the Sentinels in
turn take Forge and the only thing we're
told is that the Fate they have for him
is a fate worse than death and so
following that you switch over to year
22 right we're told in the years that
followed the Sentinels only stepped up
their aggression mutants were either
branded with M badges imprisoned in
camps or hunted by hounds non-mutant
Heroes tried to stand against the rising
fascism but not without cost because
what is up going on is the Fantastic
Four arrive on the scene and basically
encounter Rachel Summers and because
Rachel Summers has had history with
Franklin the two of them were like a
romantic couple they had a whole history
together and everything the Fantastic
Four tried to use that connection in
order to try to bring her back to
reality she basically attacks Ben Grimm
she kills the thing she destroys Reed
Richards and then Susan storm is killed
by Ahab right like the Fantastic Four
wiped out in one Fell Swoop then you
jump to year 26 and you pick up with
Banshee right Sean Cassidy this guy that
has the ability to admit a scream his
power sucks and basically he dies right
because he's one of the crappiest
mutants to ever exist in the history of
Marvel Comics the guy can scream and fly
rahu so when it comes to like this guy's
death this guy's destroyed Rachel
Summers jumps back onto the scene again
and goes after Kitty Pride this time
Rachel is basically taken out by Bishop
now why Bishops here I have no clue it's
one of the weirdest things and in fact
it flies in the face of everything we
know about the original Days of Future
Past story because what ends up
happening is Bishop is the one that
contacts Rachel Summers or really
contacts Kitty pride and tells her that
Rachel is the key to saving this entire
timeline and preventing this timeline
from ever coming into the future and in
fact he says he's from an alternate
future right another timeline which is
similar to Days of Future Past honestly
it feels like Bishop's just thrown in
here for the sake of throwing him in
here but what he does is he tells her
exactly what's supposed to happen in
order to save this timeline now assuming
that this concludes the way the original
Days of Future Past did which I don't
even know how it is and it's going to
conclude that way everything just kind
of feels so different now in essence
Rachel Summers would send the mind of
kitty Pride into the past to warn the
X-Men of what was going to happen the
X-Men would stop the assassination of
Robert Kelly and it would save the day
but I have no clue if that's what's
actually going to happen or not and
perhaps even there's no saving this
timeline what they do end up doing
though is they basically cure the
brainwashing of Rachel Summers right get
her back to her normal self and then
send her back in as an agent that's
basically been missing for some time but
is fine return that the brainwashing
process is effectively recommenced this
time with mental blocks that Rachel
herself is able to keep in place so she
never fully succumbs to it and in
response to that Rachel Summers does
kill Ahab but she's captured by the
Sentinels this explains how it is that
in the original Days of Future Past
story Rachel Summers was in an
internment camp because one of the
things to know all these characters that
you see here write like Colossus Kitty
Pride Rachel Summers storm Magneto and
so on they all end up in a concentration
camp right where mutants are basically
being held with Magneto it's going to be
a little bit interesting here in a
second because I'm curious how you take
it but what we do is we switch over to
year 28 and where you have Colossus and
kitty Pride who were on the Run trying
to escape these Sentinels that are
coming after them the Sentinels wipe out
their kits literally the Sentinels take
their kids out just completely and
totally incinerate them following that
Colossus initially wants to go after the
Sentinels But ultimately doesn't now
while we're not explicitly told here
what it looks like is the Sentinels have
officially taken over that Humanity no
longer has any involvement in any of
this the Sentinels have taken over
everything there doesn't really seem to
be a clear delineation as to when that
happened but at the very least that
seems to be the case and so by year 29
right 29 years after all this has
started you pick up in the internment
camp and of course you do have Franklin
Richards and you've got Rachel Summers
who more or less make amends and
everything kind of gets sorted but what
you do at that point is you jump over to
Wolverine who's met by the arrival of
Magneto and the two of them have never
really reconciled their differences
after the death of Gene and so this is
like the first time they've met since
the funeral and that initial
conversation when Magneto walked away
but one of the things to know about the
original Days of Future Past is that
Wolverine was actually working with the
North American resistance meaning he and
other mutants that were out there that
hadn't been captured were operating
inside Canada which largely became a
kind of safe haven for those mutants
that didn't stay in North America and he
would occasionally travel to the United
States which would basically become a
safe haven for those mutants that didn't
stay in the United States and that in
turn he would travel back and forth
between Canada and the states either
helping people escape the us or bringing
information to those who needed it and
taking pot shots against the Sentinels
where he could when he could but what
Magneto does here in kind of a weird
decision I don't really know why Marvel
did this but they basically say that
like the Sentinels have found a way to
weaponize the planet Itself by causing
like environmental Calamity right it
kind of seems unnecessary seems a little
over the top and seems like it's
injected here for no real logical reason
but they're basically using Scarlet
Witch to do it so Magneto leading a
resistance force consisting of uh
Wolverine and Jubilee ends up going in
rescuing Wanda maximoff Wanda is taken
by Wolverine out of the entire facility
but not before she destroys the machine
and kind of tells Magneto keep on
fighting whatever you do just keep going
and so Magneto stays behind he's
attacked by the Sentinels that arrive on
the scene and he's impaled presumably
Magneto's dead unlike the last days of
future past or the original Days of
Future Past where he was simply
handicapped with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end the
final issue comes out in two weeks let
me know down in the comments whether or
not you want to want me to cover it and
I will catch you all later
peace